fx's hit show American Horror Story has  displayed some of the best visual  effects in the genre particularly in  freak show this particular season is  based around a small traveling circus  searching for new and exciting acts to  help it compete with the Advent of  Television the job of bringing these  unique characters to life went to fuse  FX which had been working on American  Horror Story since the first season  freak's show presented some unique  challenges however like adding a second  head to actor Sarah Paulson VFX  supervisor Jason piccione told Post  Magazine most of the time both of her  sides are shot on green screen we've got  a couple of Rigs of prosthesis that she  can wear for doing a wide shot with a  prosthetic head or where we are in an  over and we want to see the two heads of  all the roles she had taken on Paulson  called the Dual role of conjoined twins  bet and Dot her craziest part yet